mitten im schleswig holsteinischen
reinfeldt gut versteckt hinter einem
zaun steht diese brücke stolze 175000
euro hat der bau gekostet mit der brücke
soll der tiefer liegende stadtteil
besser mit dem höher liegenden zentrum
verbunden werden
aber das hat die stadt seit sage und
schreibe neun jahren nicht geschafft so
lange steht das bauwerk schon sinnlos in
der gegend herum
ich finde das ist ein skandal dass die
brücke gebaut wird und jetzt nicht
genutzt werden kann
es ärgert mich dass das geld so aus dem
fenster geworfen wird bekloppt ist wohl
das richtige wort weil ich gehe davon
aus dass die baubehörde ja sich mal was
dabei gedacht hat
im april 2010 wird die brücke gebaut der
grund am reinfelder herrenteich wird ein
neues seniorenwohnheim errichtet damit
die alten herrschaften besser ins höher
gelegene zentrum kommen plant die stadt
eine brücke samt aufzug und treppe die
bittere realität sieht aber so aus die
brücke ist gespart völlig zugewachsen
und kann nicht genutzt werden
auf dem nachbargrundstück sollte
eigentlich das nagelneue rathaus center
entstehen und zeitgleich dazu der
brücken anschluss gebaut werden doch auf
der brache kommt nicht in die gänge und
die brücke steht nutzlos herum
bürgermeister heiko gastmann hat das
projekt von seinem vorgänger geerbt
trotz allem hält er es nicht für eine
fehlplanung also moment macht das noch
keinen sinn das ist richtig deswegen
bestehen wir darauf dass die treppe
unter falscher tatsächlich gebaut wird
erst dann ergibt sich da sind gott sei
dank ist die brücke ja noch nicht
korrodiert oder so was sie hat im moment
ist im moment in ihrem dornröschenschlaf
wach küssen wird immer schwieriger denn
durch die endlos planung sind die
baukosten mittlerweile explodiert das
führte dazu dass wir ursprünglich mit
380.000 euro baukosten gerechnet haben
und wir haben angebot über 800 47.000
euro bekommen also deutlich höher als
kalkuliert haben in reinfeld fragen sich
die menschen wie die stadt das problem
lösen will
ohne noch mehr geld zu verbrennen denn
schließlich habe ich das mit bezahlt
über mein steuergeld und wenn es nicht
genutzt werden kann
dann muss man sich mal überlegen wo
bleibt das geld die planung stimmt
einfach nicht wenn man plant was man
baut irgendwas hin
und bringt es nicht zu ende das ist
traurig also ich finde das ist nicht
gerade aus der portokasse zu bezahlen
nicht also das ist schon ein haufen geld
und wenn man sowas in angriff nimmt
sollte man das auch zu ende bauen die
menschen aus dem seniorenwohnheim werden
sich noch weiter darüber ärgern müssen
denn bei der stadt weiß derzeit niemand
wann die brücke endlich genutzt werden
kann